[Music]
on this tuesday night new urgency about
the spread of covid19
we had a bit of a crossroads canada's
top doctor on how to avoid
another lockdown a canadian woman
accused of trying to poison the u.s
president appears in court the letters
the tweets and the alleged threats
and bracing for hurricane teddy the
parking lot here will likely be
underwater the menacing storm barreling
toward atlantic canada
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is no way to sugarcoat the
trajectory this country is on when it
comes to cobit 19. cases are going up
they're accelerating fast in some
regions especially in people aged
20 to 39 and if you're tired of hearing
it from people like me
and from public health officers and
political leaders just look at the
numbers
this is the graph from the newest
federal projections if we keep doing
what we're doing now case numbers will
skyrocket in the coming weeks and months
if we increase contact with other people
more than we're doing now the virus will
spread
even faster but if we step up
precautions and
decrease who we come into contact with
public health officials believe we can
get coveted cases back to a slow burn
here are today's daily case numbers
these are people who became infected
sometime in the past two
weeks the bulk of new cases are still in
the four biggest provinces
ontario is reporting 478 new cases today
the biggest jump since may
quebec has almost 500 new cases out west
there are 150
new cases in alberta and 96 in bc
right now canada is at a crossroads in
the fight against covid19
and if we don't act fast to slow the
spread public health experts warn
we're headed down a dangerous path david
aiken has our top story
tonight my message today is the time is
now we're at a bit of a crossroads
a crossroads canada's top public health
official says
a choice between continuing with schools
and businesses
reopening or a potential return to the
lockdowns of the spring
it's not surprising to have increasing
cases in the fall we've actually
said this can happen but now you've got
to just keep
things under control without the full
lockdown
dr teresa tam said this unsurprising new
wave of infections the second wave
is different from the first wave this
surge is a very different surge to the
previous wave
it is younger people right now we're
seeing that the mortality is lower
the hospitalizations are lower but that
could quickly change
it's going to spill over into high-risk
populations hence a call by canada's
health minister to show more
self-restraint we have to get better at
saying no
more than yes to the invitations that
we're receiving to gather
for barbecues in the backyard or
you know parties to celebrate occasions
another key difference this time much
higher testing capacity
and more knowledge about tracing and
breaking the transmission chain
those factors may help smooth the
transmission curve
into some lower peaks and valleys we
want to keep it at low
moguls we don't want it to go up a giant
ski hill and then again
and to keep the rate of transmission at
what tam called a slow burn
she said it's crucial canadians do their
part wash hands frequently
maintain physical distance wear a mask
when distancing is difficult and
stay home if experiencing any symptoms
even mild ones
and local public health authorities have
to do their part too with beefed up
testing capacity
robust tracing and resources to respond
to outbreaks
as for the federal government look to
tomorrow's speech from the throne
for commitments to families to give them
the financial cushion they need
to make the right health decisions and
commitments to provinces and local
health authorities
to give them the resources to beat the
virus back
one final thing donna prime minister
justin trudeau plans to give a televised
prime time address tomorrow to
underscore the urgency
of dealing with this second wave david
aiken in ottawa thanks
the family of conservative leader aaron
o'toole who has kovit 19
is dealing with another setback his wife
rebecca o'toole has now
also tested positive the conservative
party says the couple's two children
are being monitored for symptoms the
city of ottawa is cracking down on rule
breakers a record 93 new cases of
covid19 were reported there today and
the city's chief medical officer
has ordered that anyone who has the
virus has been in contact with a
positive case
or is waiting for a test result will be
fined up to five thousand dollars a day
if they don't self-isolate for 14 days
and ontario announced today what it says
is the largest flu shot campaign in that
province's
history it's investing 70 million
dollars to administer
5.1 million doses of flu vaccine to
residents
it's part of a six pillar plan to
prepare for a second wave
health officials warn it could hit even
harder than the first though as jeff
semple reports the health care system
this time
appears much more prepared the first
wave of covid 19 last spring
sent hospitals scrambling building more
capacity
and canceling non-emergency surgeries
fast forward six months
they're looking and sounding much more
prepared for a potential
second wave it's such a different
scenario from march and april
we know about our ppe our personal
protective equipment we've got lots of
it we have a stable supply
we communicate a lot with each other
canada's covet 19 cases are climbing to
levels not seen since early may
how you define the second wave is up for
up for grabs but
all the indications are that we should
be
very concerned with what's happening
this calgary hospital is suddenly
scrambling to contain two covid19
outbreaks which have killed at least two
patients and infected around
20 others those are still under
investigation so we're still trying to
determine exactly
how the introduction happened the good
news for hospitals is that the vast
majority of new covet 19 cases are
young adults in their 20s and 30s few of
whom require hospitalization
the potential bad news what happens when
the kovid 19 pandemic
meets the flu season certainly that's
something that
causes me to consume a lot of tums
worrying about that this toronto area
hospital which just built this pandemic
response unit
typically runs out of beds during a
regular flu season
we need to place a great deal of
emphasis on
making sure that we mitigate the effects
of the flu season that everyone gets
their flu shot
to that end ontario just announced its
largest ever flu vaccine campaign
ordering more than 5 million doses but
the next wave
it will come at us harder than the last
one quebec which has already declared
its second wave
is now urging health care workers
including dentists and midwives to help
with testing
and contact tracing we have been working
since last week to
increase our screening capacity but this
is not enough
indeed these long lineups at testing
centers in different cities
a reminder that while we're better
prepared there's still a long way
to go jeff semple global news toronto
england is trying to avoid another full
lockdown as cases there
rise coming up the about face from prime
minister boris johnson as he addresses
the nation tonight
first some breaking news from the
federal courthouse in buffalo new york
pascal ferrier the canadian woman
charged with mailing a letter laced with
a deadly toxin to the american president
has made her first court appearance she
pleaded not guilty
an fbi affidavit filed in court says
when ferrier was detained september 20th
at the peacebridge border crossing
attempting to cross into the u.s
she told american border officers she
was wanted by the fbi for the ricin
letters
it says she was in possession of a
loaded firearm in her belt
as well as a knife abigail beeman
listened to the court proceedings today
abigail what happened
donna the judge entered a not guilty
plea on pascal ferrier's behalf a french
interpreter was used for the hearing
though
ferrier gave some one-word yes answers
and the judge acknowledged
she has substantial knowledge of english
ferrier's case was put over
until next week court heard the u.s
intends to push back against
bail noting the charge involved a crime
of violence
and saying she posed a serious risk of
flight she was assigned a public
defender
she has a presumption of innocence and
that will be
pursued further after
abigail you read true the affidavit
filed in court today
what does it reveal about her arrest and
the allegations against her
well donna the affidavit was written by
an fbi special agent and he alleges
there were
seven letters in total one sent to the
president
and six sent to texas penitentiaries and
detention centers
let's look at the letter to donald trump
first it gives some clues about a
possible motive
the author calls the president the ugly
tyrant clown
saying he ruins the united states it
tells him to
give up and remove your application for
this election
the letter talks about a quote special
gift for trump and notes
if it doesn't work i'll find better
recipe for another poison
or i might use my gun when i'll be able
to come enjoy
signed free rebel spirit the fbi
confirmed the substance
in the envelope was the poison ricin and
they found
pascal ferrier by tracking people with
canadian connections
who were arrested or spent time
imprisoned in texas
ferrier had been arrested there for
weapons possession last year
court records show the charges were
dismissed she was released soon after
and transferred into the custody of u.s
immigration and customs enforcement
according to the fbi the other six
letters were sent to people affiliated
with the facilities where she was held
and all the letters shared one line if
it doesn't work
i will find a better recipe there are
still unanswered questions here and a
big one is about that so-called recipe
how did someone get their hands on ricin
for seven letters
and not expose themselves to danger
considering just a pinhead amount
can kill donna abigail beeman in ottawa
thanks
so who is pascal ferrier and where has
she spent the last few years
mike armstrong set out to find some
answers by speaking to people
who know her
diane says she knew the face immediately
but it took a minute to place the woman
suspected of sending rice and laced
letters
lived at chamberlain's campsite south of
montreal for the entire summer of 2018.
chamberlain says the more recent photos
look very
different aleppo lame
she doesn't have the same look in her
eyes shawn balance says it's like
something changed
pascal ferrari appears to have kept two
facebook accounts with them you're able
to piece together her life over the last
several years
this was her citizenship ceremony in
november of 2015
she immigrated to canada from france a
year later on a twitter account under
her name
there's a post that she seemed to be fed
up with quebec winters and was preparing
to start a new life
well she purchased this rv in the fall
of 2017
and started living in it full time the
next spring ferry moved to a campsite
northwest of montreal but according to
the owner
left after just one month without paying
that's when she moved to chamberlain's
campsite staying for the rest of the
summer
she removed the table in the rv and
replaced it with a desk
running a web design company from it
says she worked out of the rv she was
quiet and they never had any trouble at
all
well in october of 2018 she headed south
for texas
taking with her a travel companion
everything seemed fine right through to
a post on new year's eve
now there's nothing on her social media
about her arrest
march 12 2019 in southern texas she was
picked up on firearm related charges
ferry would spend time in jail she was
released in may
and then headed back to canada she
posted this video from a diner in
arkansas
updating friends saying she was headed
north
well back in canada she doesn't appear
to have found a job in her field right
away she worked at this grocery store
outside montreal for five months
this woman says she was shocked to see
her former colleague on the front page
of newspapers
she says ferry never talked politics or
said anything about having been arrested
ferry found a new job over the winter
her online cv says she was a software
configuration manager here
that new job was just a two minute drive
from the location
raided by police and soldiers monday
global news has confirmed it was
ferry's apartment she was two months
into a one-year lease
mike armstrong global news montreal
we are watching this tonight hurricane
teddy churning across the north atlantic
heading for nova scotia
it's still a category two hurricane but
it's expected to lessen
to a post-tropical storm when it makes
landfall tomorrow
that is still bad though strong winds
are expected to whip up
huge waves swells of up to 10 meters
could bring significant
flooding to coastal areas near halifax
tonight people living in high risk
regions along the shoreline are being
asked to evacuate immediately
our ross lord is further to the east in
port hastings on cape breton island
ross well donna this wind and rain
is just an early taste of what's coming
as teddy bears
down on atlanta canada mark dacey just
arrived in cape breton on a sailing trip
with his wife and their son
despite emerging from quarantine they're
in no position to cut loose
in fact they're doubling down on their
rope lines we've also tied around
the dock the lines around the dock
rather than on the cleats
because there is a strong chance in
these conditions that the cleats will
rip out
the canadian hurricane center placed the
entire south coast of nova scotia under
a tropical storm warning
emergency planners say losing hurricane
status
doesn't make teddy harmless i know
people are attracted to the shoreline
they love to watch the waves
i just want to caution folks please stay
back back at the yacht club they're
worried about what will happen when
winds
shift on wednesday during the expected
height of the storm
if we get a hit the that south west wind
at a high tide with a surge yeah we we
could experience some difficulties and
the
parking lot here will likely be uh
underwater we're going to be
uh in the top floor of their building in
sleeping bags
because uh it's not safe to be on a boat
in this kind of weather
by way of context hurricane juan in 2003
did 200 million dollars worth of damage
and is blamed for four deaths
hurricane dorian last year also left a
trail of devastation
forecasters say teddy is no one and no
dorian
but it could still be dangerous donna
ross lord on cape breton island tonight
thanks
we are going to keep tracking teddy's
path a little later our chief
meteorologist tells us where
exactly it is and when it will hit
britain's prime minister addressed the
nation tonight warning of a long winter
ahead
boris johnson is reimposing tough public
health restrictions because covid19 is
spreading again
there are almost 5 000 new positive
tests in 24 hours there the highest
daily numbers since early may
johnson who himself had coveted and
ended up in intensive care
chastised young people who don't seem to
care saying
your mild cough can be someone else's
death knell
crystal commansing reports we must take
action now because the stitching time
saves nine and this way
we can keep people in work we can keep
our shops and our schools open and we
can keep our country
moving forward a plea from the british
prime minister as
tough new restrictions come into effect
in pubs for example there's no more
standing only
table service is permitted and only
until 10.
we're keen to reduce the amount of hours
pubs bars and restaurants can be opened
because that leads to unfortunately
greater socialization and the virus
spread in
as well servers must now wear masks
along with taxi drivers
and retail workers the top new measures
could stay in place
until spring that's something the head
of uk hospitality says
could lead to more job losses we just
reached that tipping point where we
might be able to stand on our own two
feet
and this will knock us right back to
where we were in july because of the the
negative impact on consumer confidence
and fines are rising for those who don't
comply
the military is on standby to ensure
officers
aren't spread too thin as they focus on
enforcement
anyone who can do their job from home is
being told
not to go into the office johnson says
there is no
alternative and isn't ruling out more
restrictions
crystal gamson global news london
carbon tax in the supreme court ahead
the highest court hears arguments about
canada's climate plan
a fight over the federal carbon tax is
now in front of canada's highest court
appeals from three provinces are being
heard alberta saskatchewan and ontario
argue
the tax is unconstitutional as eric
sorenson reports the case could have
implications
far beyond the issue of climate change
it has been a tumultuous political and
legal path to the supreme court
at stake provincial versus federal
powers the policy
climate change one of the great issues
of our time the time
is now to take real action
five years ago the trudeau government
promised then implemented national
pollution pricing to reduce greenhouse
gases
but as more conservative premiers came
to power the politics grew contentious
we will beat the carbon tax i can assure
you of this
and the legal battles began three
provincial challenges and a split
decision
the courts of appeal in saskatchewan and
ontario sided with ottawa's contention
that carbon emissions do not respect
provincial boundaries
and require a national response
alberta's high court concluded
the federal law encroaches on provincial
powers over natural resources
and now nine supreme court justices have
returned to the courtroom
for the first time since the pandemic
began to hear historic arguments over
the division of powers in this country
this is a reference that will shape the
federation for a generation
provincial lawyers suggested the law
gives ottawa coercive powers over the
provinces
and not just on climate change there's a
risk of provincial non-cooperation
there's no doubt
that the provinces acting collectively
can regulate every activity within their
borders
some justices push back suggesting the
federal law allows provinces to meet
standards
set out but it seems to me they've left
you guys a whole lot of power the
government of canada arguing a national
standard is needed to fight climate
change
pricing across the country
is an essential tool this case is about
whether or not canada
can join the rest of the world in taking
joint action to tackle climate change
but provincial jurisdiction is important
for justices to consider
the balance of federalism between
federal and provincial governments is
always critical to maintaining
a healthy federalism in canada the court
will hear from environmental groups and
other interveners on wednesday
a ruling may not come for several months
eric sorensen global news
toronto next tracking teddy as atlantic
canada braces
for a powerful storm
we want to take you back to what's
happening in atlantic canada as
hurricane teddy approaches
with me is global news chief
meteorologist anthony farnell anthony
lots of warnings and watches in effect
how big is this storm donna teddy is
massive since early yesterday morning it
has almost
doubled in size the center right here
still expected to make landfall sometime
late
wednesday morning or early afternoon to
the east
of halifax but really it's the size of
this system that matters
tropical storm force winds extending out
upwards of
850 kilometers away and all of that wind
well it's setting a lot of water in
motion already reports of
50 or more foot waves offshore
from nova scotia but that wave action
when you combine with a storm surge and
high tides
tonight and again on wednesday that's
going to cause most of the problems with
teddy of course there is rain there's
wind to contend with as well
50 to 75 millimeters and
those wind gusts right along coastal
areas that at times
could be above 100 kilometers per hour
thankfully teddy is moving quickly
and by late wednesday night conditions
are going to
improve and then the cleanup begins
donna
all right anthony farnell thanks
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm donna friesen tonight's your canada
is this beautiful scene from the
district of stuart in northwestern bc
near the alaskan border
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye
you